part of your job in senior leadership is
to embody love of the brand
which doesn't necessarily mean you know
being a preacher it doesn't you don't
have to necessarily stand on stages but
you do get to find fun ways to bring it
to life like starting a meeting like you
can start every meeting talking about it
like dick Robinson who used to run
Scholastic they had an amazing cause
which is to inspire children to love
reading and he would bring it up in
every meeting remember what our cause is
it's to inspire kids celebrity who's
constantly reminding people and people
loved it and believed in it it's why
they worked there I bring up our cause
we imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do I talk about it
constantly I bring it up in our own
meetings with our own team I make no
assumptions that everybody knows it no
matter how many times they've heard me
say it and I think I think that's what
it means to be a preacher